- The team care.
We don't have 32, but we
have select members of
the Medical Therapy
Unit of San Mateo County
who bravely are covering what 32
might cover in another context.
(audience laughing)
And so it's my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Christina Buysse,
who is a developmental-behavioral
pediatrician
at Packard Children's at Stanford
with a special interest in working with
children with motor disabilities.
She spends time at Stanford
Spina Bifida Clinic
and in the California Children's Service
Medical Treatment Program.
And I'll let her introduce Helen Phung,
who is a PT supervisor at CCS in San Mateo
and Patty Walsh, who's the
chief therapist at CCS.
We're thrilled to have you here.
And would you, are you planning to present
individually or jointly?
- [Woman] We're gonna present jointly.
- Okay, great.
- So that was quite a talk to follow
and I think it illustrated
well the complexity of
taking care of kids with
cerebral palsy, in particular,
and other motor disabilities.
One of the things I like best about my job
as a developmental-behavioral pediatrician
is that I often get to work
on inter-disciplinary teams.
I see some of my colleagues from my
developmental-behavioral
field out in the audience
and I'm gonna be working with
two ladies today in this talk
who each have over 30 years of experience
working at the San Mateo
medical therapy unit,
working with children
with CP, CCS, or with CP.
So these ladies have
over 60 years together,
working in this field.
And the CCS Medical Therapy unit,
one thing that has really impressed me,
and what makes it different
than some of the other
inter-disciplinary teams that I work on
is that it's a place where we're
not working to find a cure,
we're not working to make quick fixes
or to solve problems that are acute
and then kind of go away.
It's a place where
children can be seen from
the first year of life until they're 21,
as often as one to four times a week.
So relationships are formed in this clinic
and milestones are celebrated,
disappointments are
shared with the family.
So it's a really unique
place in my work profile,
where I get to kind of see
what it looks like day to day,
to help parents through
the grieving process
and to work through the
developmental milestones
that all children have,
such as middle school,
high school, graduation, things like that.
Helen and Patty have been
practicing family-centered care
and shared decision making since
before those terms were even coined.
It's a really impressive
place and I'm just
a part-time member of the team,
but wanted to share what's going on there.
Okay, so we have no disclosures.
This is our clinic.
This is a school, and in
this school and another one
is where the medical
therapy program is housed.
California Children's Services
was established in 1927
by the State of California to provide
medical care coordination
for children birth to 21.
And there's a, I'm gonna be
talking about CCS Administration
and the CCS Medical Therapy Program.
And they're two different entities
under the umbrella of CCS.
So the eligibility for CCS is based on
medical diagnosis and county of residence.
And, again, it consists of CCS
Administration and the MTP.
The administration program is administered
by each county in the state of California.
And it arranges, directs, and pays for
medical care, equipment,
and rehabilitation
for children with specific diagnoses.
And there's a wide range of diagnoses
that are CCS Administration-eligible,
from genetic to endocrine
disorders to neoplasms
to different neuromuscular disorders.
Clients must be both medically
and financially eligible
to receive CCS Administration services.
There is a CCS pilot project
that was started in 2014
in the San Mateo Medical Center.
Senate Bill 586 determined that
the Department of Health Care Services
should establish a
Whole-Child Model program.
And this incorporated the CCS services
under the Medi-Cal managed care plan,
or Health Plan San Mateo
in San Mateo County.
And this has been going on, and in this,
CCS San Mateo has a contract
with Health Plan San Mateo
to do their care coordination.
And what's different
about the pilot program
is that it improves care
coordination for CCS children
for both their CCS and
their non-CCS conditions.
Meaning that if a child who has diabetes,
and therefore has a CCS
Administration care coordination,
if they break their arm
while playing baseball,
that orthopedic surgery
will be covered, you know,
will be coordinated under the
care coordination of the CCS.
This project maintains the CCS
program standards unchanged,
including that the
services are provided by
CCS paneled providers.
And it's a comprehensive treatment plan
that focuses on the whole child.
So far, we're happy to say that
there's been minimal impact
on the availability of services
at the Medical Therapy Program
through this project program.
And I believe it's gonna be unveiled
in six other counties
in the next few months,
and maybe even further
over the next few years.
So now let's talk about the
Medical Therapy Program.
This was established about 20 years after
the CCS Administration, in 1945.
It's funded half and half by
the state and by the counties.
And the Medical Therapy
Program specifically provides
physical and occupational therapy,
for children with specific
medical diagnoses.
So in our county, and probably others,
the speech therapy and
other developmental services
for children with these medical diagnoses
are provided by the regional center.
The eligibility for children and families
to enroll in the MTP does not
require financial eligibility.
So we have a quite wide range
of socio-economic status
in our patients at the
Medical Therapy Program.
They do have to live in
the county of residence
and the main determining factor
is the medical diagnosis.
Children are served from birth,
or time of diagnosis
or concerns, to age 21.
And the services are
provided in two schools
in San Mateo County, pictured
here, and one satellite.
And people are brought to the clinic
that is closes to their home.
Anybody can refer to the CCS MTP.
Parents can refer, teachers,
any medical professionals, social workers.
The only requirements for the
referral are an application,
which can be downloaded at the URL
that's listed on this slide,
a current medical report,
and a doctor's prescription for
the first OT and PT evaluation.
Because the MD or myself, or whoever else
is doing the medical care conference,
will not be seeing the child until
after they've already begun their,
had their evaluation and begun therapy.
The eligible diagnoses for the
CCS Medical Therapy Program
are neurologic, so children
with cerebral palsy
make up the vast majority
of children in the MTP,
but we also see kids with spina bifida,
spinal cord injuries,
traumatic brain injuries,
and I'll talk a little
bit about the diagnosis of
at risk for cerebral palsy,
under the age of three.
Orthopedic diagnoses are seen,
including osteogenesis imperfecta,
arthritis, arthrogryposis, amputations.
And we also neuromuscular disorders,
such as spinal muscular
atrophy and muscular dystrophy.
So the kids who are at risk for CP,
this is an eligible diagnosis that raises
the most questions and concern,
so I just wanted to talk a
little bit more about it.
Children can be applicants for
CCS under three years of age
if they have two or more of
the following neurological findings.
So if a primary care physician is worried
because a child has
persistent primitive reflexes
and increased DTRs, or abnormal posturing,
or hypotonicity or
asymmetry of motor findings,
then they're referred and at age three
we make a determination if that child
indeed has cerebral palsy,
or maybe a neurologist or someone else
makes that diagnosis prior to age three.
But by age three, if
we have determined that
the child does not have cerebral palsy,
then their services are
transitioned to the school district
or to other providers for their
occupational and physical therapy needs.
So we're gonna go through
the lives of three children
to kind of demonstrate
what we do at the clinic.
And we're gonna start out with Ava.
She is an adorable girl
who is now three years old.
She was born at 36 weeks gestation.
She was small for gestational
age and stayed in the NICU
for about two weeks
working on feeding issues
and also with temperature instability.
When she came into our CCS MTP program
she was about 11 months old.
And she was referred by
her primary care physician
because she was not yet
sitting independently,
she was using her right
hand more than her left,
her lower extremities
demonstrated hypertonia,
and so we accepted her into the program
with a diagnosis of at
risk for cerebral palsy.
And you can see on the
growth curve at the right
that the upper one is her height
and the lower one is her weight.
She was well below the third percentile
for her weight, height,
and head circumference,
which is not pictured here.
So over time, she continued
to grow very slowly
and has never been above
the third percentile
for weight, height, or head circumference.
She had a head MRI, which was normal.
Some facial differences were noted
and because of this, genetic
testing was performed.
The initial round was normal,
but a second round of genetic testing
revealed a diagnosis, which
explained her growth difficulty,
developmental difficulties,
and her physical findings.
Over time, feeding has continued
to be a challenge for Ava.
She is currently syringe fed,
and she's been working with
occupational therapy on
her oral motor skills
since she came into our program.
She does, however, have
nice fine motor skills,
so the occupational therapist
has been able to focus
mainly on oral motor skills.
She over time, at about 18 months of age,
began to sit unsupported and then crawl
and then stand independently.
At three years of age, she's still
not quite walking independently.
But she does use all of
her limbs symmetrically,
she requires no braces or equipment,
and she has quite limited language,
despite receiving speech therapy
through the regional center
for the past couple of years.
So at age three, Ava came in to
our medical therapy conference
and we had our meeting,
which the families attend as
well as the physical therapist,
occupational therapist, a family liaison,
sometimes a social worker,
depending on the needs of the child,
and we had a nice discussion.
At that time, she was taking
one or two steps when held,
she had nice movement
patterns that suggested
she's capable of walking
without assistance,
she had completely normal muscle tone
and deep tendon reflexes and was using
her arms and legs symmetrically.
So at that visit, we did not give
a qualifying diagnosis of cerebral palsy,
which was sad for us,
because we love this family
and she's a really sweet girl.
So she's not gonna continue
the services at CCS MTU
after turning three,
but instead her services
will be transitioned
to the school district
and to private therapists for
her ongoing OT and PT needs.
- The child is first evaluated
at an initial assessment.
The family is met by our parent
liaison and social worker
for the first part of the hour.
Then, the PT supervisor and therapy chief
do a brief assessment using
several of those listed
and make a determination as to whether
the child would benefit from OT and PT.
At the initial assessment,
the CCS program is
explained to the parents,
as well as expectations
for their participation.
Other resources that the
family may qualify for
are also provided.
Once the child is assigned
to one of our therapists,
they will do a much
more in-depth assessment
using those listed.
Strength may be determined
using a manual muscle test
depending on the child's
ability to follow instructions.
But if they aren't, then
the therapist simply
watches them move and sees
what they're capable of doing.
Activities of daily living.
This includes all self-care activities
and takes into consideration
the age of the child.
It can range from oral
motor and feeding skills
to dressing and basic hygiene.
For the older children, it might include
higher-level activities
like making a grocery list,
going to the store, and
making a simple meal.
Fine motor skills.
The OTs focus on upper extremity use,
including reach, grasp, and release,
prehensile patterns, and manual dexterity.
Gross motor skills.
Both OTs and PTs work to
improve gross motor skills.
OTs focus on the development
of self-care activities
while the PTs work on mobility and gait.
The therapist may provide
individual treatments
or co-treat together.
A co-treatment session consists
of both therapists present.
This provides an extra set of hands
to facilitate the desired
patten of movement
in order to achieve the therapy goal.
So for example, if they
were helping the child
learn to remove the jacket,
the PT might work on weight
shift and trunk rotation
while the OT would work
on arm and hand control.
Gait.
Our PTs work to get the kids mobile
using their individual
strengths and abilities.
Many children walk well
without any assistive devices
while others rely on them.
Braces often play an important role
in providing support,
alignment, and stability.
Balance is key in performing any activity.
Therapists build balance
activities into their therapy
from the very beginning.
Here you see a little girl on a swing,
someone on a vibration board,
and someone on a balance beam.
Posture and alignment.
Therapists focus on both
posture and alignment
in order to teach kids
how to best engage muscles
that will enable them to
maximize their strength
and range of motion
and move with fluidity.
The goal is to minimize long-term effects
from poor alignment that could lead to
chronic pain and further disability.
How are therapy services determined?
This is a list of
commonly used assessments
that are standardized.
They're selected depending on
the child's ability and age.
Most children entering our program
between infancy and six years are assessed
using the Peabody Developmental Scale
in order to obtain a baseline of
their fine and gross motor abilities.
And the classification scales,
Dr. Chamber went into
lots of detail on that.
There's three kinds:
the gross motor scale,
the fine motor scale, and
the communication scale,
each having a rating of one to five,
five being the most involved.
The scales have been extremely
helpful, like he said,
for everyone to have
the same mental picture
of how the child performs.
- So, once the objective
data has been collected,
the therapists work with
parents, oh, let me.
Oh, okay.
Therapists work with parents and the kid
to determine functional goals.
The COPM, or the Canadian
Occupational Performance Measure
is a tool in which the parent
and the child, if appropriate,
list skills that they want to do,
need to do, or are expected to do.
After the goals are established,
the therapists develop a treatment plan.
And the treatment can include
the hands-on treatment,
and it could be separate
OT and PT sessions
or it could be a co-treatment.
The sessions could also be provided in
an intensive treatment model,
in which a child receives
frequent therapy sessions, maybe
two to three times per week
for a number of weeks, up to 12 weeks,
to work on a very
specific functional goal.
This is paired with a home program
to practice and incorporate
in the normal home routine.
There are multiple factors that go into
determining therapy frequency.
And I know this is a question
a lot of parents have,
how do therapists determine
how often the child is getting therapy?
Over time that a child is seen at CCS,
their frequency will change
based on their needs.
A child is seen more often
when they're making changes
as a result of hands-on therapy.
And an increase in therapy
could be a result of,
after a surgery or procedure.
It could be because a child is motivated
to achieve a new goal, or if
they have new equipment needs.
For example, they're
working on power mobility
and then you need to determine access
and they need practice
with driving skills.
A decrease in therapy could be
if the goal is to just maintain skills,
if the child is not
interested or motivated
to participate in therapy at that time,
and when the family is more independent
in their home program and in handling
their equipment and bracing.
A decrease in therapy
frequency does not mean
that therapy will not increase again
because therapists are constantly
reevaluating the frequency.
Besides OT and PT services,
the medical therapy program
includes MTC, or the CCS clinics.
And this is a team meeting with the child,
the parents, the
therapists, the physician,
the parent liaison, and social worker.
In San Mateo County, the
way that we divide kids up
for the medical therapy conference,
kids birth to six years old see
a developmental pediatrician,
like Dr. Buysse.
Kids seven to 11 see a physiatrist.
When they turn 12 and
until they're 21 they see
a physiatrist who
specializes in transitions.
If they have orthopedic needs,
they see an orthopedist.
And the kids who have Kaiser
see a Kaiser physiatrist
who comes to the medical therapy unit.
Because Kaiser sends their physiatrist
to the medical therapy unit,
Kaiser kids are the only kids
with HMO that are seen in
the medical therapy clinics.
Kids are seen at the
medical therapy conference
every six months if they
have active therapy,
which is once a week or more often,
and every 12 months if they
have monitoring therapy,
which is less than once a week.
The role of the physician at
the medical therapy conference
is to determine medical
eligibility at age three,
to supervise the therapy
program, recommend equipment,
make referrals to specialists,
provide hip surveillance with x-rays,
and help with transition planning.
We also have a social worker.
And the social worker's
role is to provide resources
for the family regarding
housing, social security,
health insurance conservatorship.
He helps providing information
on transition for kids approaching 21,
makes referrals to psycho-social services,
and helps find financial assistance
from charitable organizations.
We also have a parent liaison.
She has a child who's 11 years old
who has been in our program
since he was six months old.
She provides support to families
from a parent's perspective,
helps families with navigating
the school system, the
regional center system.
She connects families with each
other, runs a parent group,
she does our bulletin boards
and our parent newsletter.
We also have durable
medical equipment clinics,
in which vendors come to
the medical therapy unit
to evaluate for, deliver,
and repair equipment.
The child, the family, and the therapist
are all present at these clinics.
In addition, the therapists help obtain
necessary documentation and prescriptions
to help families get equipment
through their insurance.
For equipment that's
covered through Medi-Cal,
the authorizations for the
equipment's actually done
in the medical therapy unit.
We also have clinics where the orthotists
come to the medical therapy unit
to evaluate, cast, and deliver braces.
And the therapists work
closely with the orthotist
to determine the fit and
function of orthoses.
We have dental clinics,
which is similar to
the dental program that Dr.
Glasman talked about yesterday.
It's provided by Ravenswood
Dental Clinic through a grant.
It's for children under 12 years old.
A dental hygienist and a dental assistant
who specialize in working
with kids with special needs
comes to the unit once a month.
And they are able to do cleanings,
x-rays, and simple treatment.
We also have monthly activities
of daily living groups.
So we provide activities
in a group setting
to work on things like
dressing, meal prep,
household chores, community
skills, such as shopping,
money management, and
public transportation.
We have a weekly exercise group.
And these are group activities
to work on strengthening,
stretching, balance, and coordination.
And we have each of these
groups at each of the sites,
so both in San Mateo and San Bruno.
We have a yearly prom, and
this started nine years ago
when some kids in the exercise group were
talking about their high
school proms and saying how
they didn't really feel
comfortable going to them.
So the first prom was planned
to help them learn about
grooming and social etiquette.
And since then, it's become a yearly event
that everyone looks forward to.
It's open to children
that are 10 years old
and their families, and older.
We have, everyone gets all dressed up,
and we have donated
clothes, to make sure that
everyone's able to come
looking their best.
It's a community effort,
with donations from local businesses
for food, decorations,
flowers, and makeup.
We have volunteers who run a makeup,
hair, and nail station before the prom,
and we have a volunteer
DJ, who plays lively tunes,
and we have photographers
throughout the event.
So just to give you a little better idea
of some of the MT services,
I wanted to meet Taylor.
Taylor had a rough start due
to fetal maternal hemorrhage,
resulting in global
brain injury, seizures,
and she was in the NICU for 12 days.
By 11 months, she
demonstrated increased tone
and reflexes in all her extremities
and asymmetrical use of her hands.
She was diagnosed with
cerebral palsy at 24 months
and started her services at 11 months
through the Early Start program,
and CCS when she was almost three.
She's now eight years
old, with a diagnosis of
spastic quadriparesis, GMSCS level four.
She has increased tone throughout,
with her legs more affected than her arms
and the left side more
affected than the right side.
She has impaired balance
and protective reactions,
impaired sensation and
visual motor skills.
She has tightness and weakness
in all her extremities
and her trunk and she has
difficulty dissociating
or isolating movement throughout.
She's able to sit independently
and turn to either side,
but she does have a rounded spine
and flexion posturing in
her arms and her legs.
She scissors at her legs.
You can see, these are two pictures.
The first was a few years
ago and the second one,
the lower one, is just recently.
And she had a selective dorsal rhizotomy
a little over a year ago.
And it has made a difference
as far as her posture
and her ability to work on some of
her independent living skills.
For fine motor, she's able
to reach over her head
without a loss of balance.
She has difficulty using her arms
and precise movement of
her fingers and hands.
She has some hypermobility
of her joints in her hands
and some hypomobility, as well.
So she uses hand splints
for fine motor function.
She's able to feed herself,
take off her socks and a shirt overhead.
She needs some help to take off
a sweater that's open in the front.
And she's able to push large
buttons through buttonholes
using a thumb splint.
For mobility, she's able
to roll, commando crawl,
and get up to sitting by herself.
She transitions to standing
with some help, contact guard,
up to kneeling, and then a
little bit more assistance
to come all the way up to standing.
She needs moderate assistance to get
from her bed to her wheelchair.
And she's dependent for
toilet and tub transfers.
She walks on level surfaces and up stairs
with moderate assistance,
but in a gait trainer she's
able to walk in an open space.
She uses a manual wheelchair
at home and in the classroom
and for longer distances
she uses power mobility,
but because of her visual motor
issues she needs supervision
and she's working with
an orientation and mobility specialist.
Her strengths are her communcation
skills and social skills.
She has age-appropriate
play skills and interests.
She's willing to try anything
and loves coming to therapy.
At the last therapy evaluation,
the OT goals were determined
by Taylor, her parents, and the OT.
And the goals are to put on
an open-front shirt or sweater
and to hike her pants up
while standing with one hand.
For PT, they came up with these goals:
stand with one arm support for 30 seconds,
and to get herself into bed
positioned in the correct orientation.
She's currently receiving twice a week PT
and twice a week OT.
Over the time that she's been at CCS,
her frequency has fluctuated between
one to four times a
week, based on her needs.
Some of the things that
they take into consideration
when considering Taylor's frequency are
the fact that she works
really hard in therapy
and by the end of the
session she looks different
than she did when she started.
She continues to progress in her skills.
She's had various orthopedic
surgeries, she's had Botox,
and she's had the
selective dorsal rhizotomy.
And she's, her age-expected
skills have changed
because she started at age three
and now she's at age eight.
So there's always
something new to work on.
The therapists have provided consultation
in a variety of settings,
including home visits and school visits.
They've also consulted with orthopedists,
especially in preparation
and after surgeries,
with neurologists, and
with the physiatrist,
especially in relation
to different muscles
that might benefit from Botox injections.
At the spasticity management
clinic it was determined,
they decided that she would go through
a selective dorsal rhizotomy.
And the therapists were
part of that team approach.
And after the rhizotomy,
the therapists consulted
very closely with the inpatient rehab team
at Children's Hospital Oakland
to ensure that the transition
from in patient rehab
to outpatient CCS Services was smooth.
The therapists have worked
very closely with the parents
to develop an home activity program.
She attends the medical therapy
conference every six months
because she's getting active therapy.
She sees a physiatrist at this time.
The therapists have
helped the families obtain
her manual wheelchair, power
wheelchair, her gait trainer,
adaptive tricycle,
stander, and toilet seat.
And the therapists have also
the family obtain her AFOs.
And she's currently on trial using a SWASH
to keep her hips in the hip abduction
because she's having a little bit of
recurrence of some hip issues.
So Taylor's come a long way,
but she has many challenges ahead
as she heads into her preteen years.
And we're gonna continue
to work with her family,
her medical providers, and teachers,
to maximize her abilities,
ensure she has the tools needed
for what lies ahead as
a teen and as an adult.
- I'd like to introduce
you now to Rebecca.
Rebecca is a 32-year-old female
with a diagnosis of spastic quadriparesis.
She's a Bay Area native,
the oldest of two girls.
Her sister is a physical therapist.
She graduated with a BA and
MA from Notre Dame de Namur
and she's a marriage and family therapist.
Her mother's pregnancy was uneventful
until about 28 weeks,
when her water broke.
Mom was hospitalized and
administered steroids
to develop the baby's lungs.
Rebecca appeared the
next week, at 29 weeks,
and was weighing in at
two pounds, 3.7 ounces.
She was only ventilated for 24 hours.
She had an NG tube for less than a month.
She was diagnosed with Tetralogy of Fallot
and in the NCIU for two months.
At six months, she had her heart surgery
to correct he Tetralogy of Fallot
and then returned home after recovery.
Rebecca's parents noticed that
she was not meeting her
developmental milestones
and they discussed this
with their pediatrician.
She was diagnosed with cerebral palsy,
spastic quadriparesis,
and then referred to
the Golden Gate Regional Center,
where she entered an Early Start program
and received PT, OT, and speech.
At age three, she was referred to CCS.
At the time, the therapist
met with her parents
and determined what was important to them.
The primary goal for both
parents was mobility,
followed by socialization,
education, and just,
they really wanted to
maximize her opportunities.
Her services after the
Golden Gate Regional Center
took place at an early
childhood education preschool,
where she benefited from the services of
a special education
teacher and classroom aids.
Housed at the same facility was one of our
medical therapy units,
where she received OT and PT
and was eligible for
services until she turned 21.
The PT did an evaluation, they
looked at her increased tone,
her decreased range of motion,
her postural alignment,
her balance, mobility, and gait,
and came up with a treatment plan
and therapy frequency, which was weekly.
The OT did a similar
assessment, looking at range,
increased tone, weakness,
postural alignment,
fine motor skills, self
care, and perception,
and also came up with a therapy plan
and recommended therapy on a weekly basis.
Early on, it was determined
that she would benefit from
a manual wheelchair, a walker, and AFOs.
At age 11, she received her power chair.
These four pieces of equipment
have remained very critical
in her mobility to this day.
And she uses them to get around the house
as well as in the community.
At age six, she had
soft tissue lengthenings
of her hip adductors, hip
flexors, and hamstrings.
PT did a home visit to
evaluate how things were going
and if additional durable
medical equipment was needed.
Rebecca's parents focused on mobility
and throughout her childhood
they took her everywhere,
did everything with her.
They enrolled her in a
variety of community programs
and they were really quite successful
in promoting her ability to
navigate her surroundings.
In her adult life, Rebecca
lives in San Francisco.
She graduated from grad school in 2010
and completed her credentials as an MFT.
She shares an apartment
and works full time.
Of importance to Rebecca is
exercising on a regular basis.
She heads to the gym in her neighborhood
two or three times a week.
And she says that it helps her feel looser
and that the benefits of
working out last a couple days.
Like other 32-year-old young ladies,
she enjoys travel, restaurants,
movies, and sporting events.
In terms of self care,
she's now independent
with upper body dressing,
she can manage clothing for toileting,
but she requires maximum assistance
to don lower extremity garments.
She's independent with basic grooming,
including putting her contacts in,
and she benefits from
assistance for bathing,
cooking, and household chores.
Rebecca is independent,
driving her own van.
She's able to enter it, transfer
out of her power wheelchair
and into the driver's seat.
She uses her van every day to get to work.
She's a very lucky individual in that
she lives in California,
where it's usually sunny.
When it rains or there's inclement weather
this can impair her mobility
and be downright hazardous.
In this picture, she's
on a glacier in Iceland
and you can see that she
depends completely on her friend
to stay in an upright
position, standing in the snow.
She loves to travel and
she's been to many countries.
She's told me that it's not
easy to find medical providers
when traveling, or even at home,
because there's a scarcity
of trained physicians
that are familiar with her condition.
Anyone who travels quite a bit
has probably had a situation
or an incident where you check
your bags, get on the plane,
and afterwards you go to the
conveyor belt and you watch
and A, you're worried that your
luggage isn't gonna show up
and B, when it does, you see that
the wheel fell off the
suitcase and the handle's torn.
With Rebecca, in addition
to accessibility,
she has to really think twice about
what equipment she takes along on a trip.
And she's told me that at
least two or three times
in her travels her
equipment's been damaged.
And whether it breaks
at home or on vacation,
it's always hard to find a provider
and it renders her immobile.
Even though she is very capable
of handling her own affairs,
getting new equipment
and dealing with repairs
is quite a deal and she
has to be very persistent.
So as you can tell from
these case studies,
we take the kids through
many stages of their lives.
At CCS, it takes teamwork
to move the kids forward
to live independently
so that they can have
fulfilling lives.
(audience applauding)